because we're living and of course you
can I can I can I cannot meet these
challenges without visa forums and
certainly in addition of course no and
the this is of course there are many
different issues like corruption force
annexed in and we worked so hard to
fight I mean all of this issue of course
and I would like from here to thank all
the countries the Chile
I mean contributed it contribute in a
major role for instance they can we can
I was always in continuity in
communication with His Royal Highness of
course no and and and he has a played an
important role for instant talk to to
talk to to talk all our counterpart in
his counterparts in other countries then
invest in love and of course Center is
based on two main issues the main points
course develop the private sector in
which is an lebanon for instance we have
worked so hard to develop the concept
that PP TPP the most of the electricity
based products water and roads and and
communications all of these baseman's
going to be based on private sector of
course no we're going to pay and in such
such sectors but it's still there and
there are a lot of other projects for
instance during this on the festival
study which shows not to be business
oriented forms of like wastewater
treatment and all of these a project
course this is going to be dealt by the
World Bank and world our and the public
investment a fine that's going to join
they are other partners to help us in
addition to the assistance that it comes
from Kuwait and other countries that
truly put just like 11 points 11 than
eleven thousand dollars and I think it's
really the Chile the forms going to
system many areas that going to
that's going to be based on changing the
hard work the work level in Lebanon and
this type of change course is going to
be for the good of Lebanon and is going
to be for the interest national interest
of Lublin certainly think and and I
think personally think that you all love
a nice people are very cautious and
fully a weird that's really that
loveling cannot go and do business as we
used to do before
so we need to actually to to create such
a forums and instead of Chile and to be
balling and and and this type of
investment of course is going to cause
it growth and as you know the chill in
Lebanon for instance the problem that we
used to suffered we have won 1 million
point five million Syrian refugees and
this is going to constitute a great big
burden on Lebanese of course in the
center and that's going to Fox an
infrastructures I think that really this
money spent is going to speed spin I'm
the country under all the projects when
instead of the growth is going to grace
to be to be submitted by turbulence its
dollars and the thing to Chile there is
going to be and the return is going to
be it could create 55,000 jobs in in so
many sectors like electricity and even
the addition to the other sectors that I
named and you think the chill you are on
track of reforms and these reforms and
all our counterparts and our partners in
the local party need to the the world we
will approve and a gray on such a forums
you know your Royal Highness and the
fourth course became very fruitful
reading at 1.9% is going to be expected
of a canonical growth this year of
course not with actually with the
reduction and cut well and the budget
deficit is going to be lower four point
seven and the next tee of course one
point seven and these are great
achievements and in however still their
son some subdolous as requires the
seriousness of of the Kingdom Saudi
Arabia in carrying out their forums the
required forms I mean the economic and
social all together does I mean Asia the
kicking of salt would be going to be on
track or forms first I ask everybody not
to believe me just look at the numbers
numbers speak louder to correct the
information you mentioned the
expectation for the exports of study are
from two point two two two point five
percent this has been revisited three
five times everyday we revisit the
numbers today to be better next year
will be better if we look at the numbers
in the past
three years we see for example that our
known oil revenues have doubled three
times tripled the budget this year is
the largest in the Saudi history the
next budget will be more than one
trillion riyals we find that the rate of
spending the capex and operation is
increasing and the the salaries is
decreasing three years ago the rate of
salaries to the budget is fifty percent
we expect next year to be forty five
percent although the the spending is
increasing and this chapter is
increasing the the percentage is
decreasing despite the employment is
increasing we believe unemployment rate
will improve until 2030 the sorry the
public investment fund was 315 million
dollars this year by the end of the year
it'll be more than four four hundred
billion so which is one of the
objectives 2020 could be achieved in
2019 so it could be by 2020 to reach a
500 billion reaching 2 trillion or more
by 2030 our position in global
competitiveness is better this has been
announced just look at the numbers don't
believe me it will explain to you where
we were and where we are and look at the
numbers next year and it will explain
more also reform in other sectors like
the cultural entertainment or sports
I believe these numbers are very clear
when looking at classifying Saudi Arabia
or rates inside Arabia or events in
Saudi Arabia there are leaps and
the Saudi Arabia in the past three years
and this is something that will no doubt
continue we live among the people that
is great once they identify and a goal
they will achieve it no obstacle is too
great for the Saudi people all our mega
projects are ongoing our war on
extremism is ongoing our war on
terrorism is ongoing developing and
upgrading the country's ongoing no
matter what they do to lower our speed
or hinder our speed they will not
succeed I get back again to ask you in
English most of the investors in this
whole how do you convince them to
customize a Omni and yet well actually
they're investing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
his royal highness stole the words out
of my mouth the people are investing in
behind and the good news is that in 2015
FBI was about 65 million dollars just
doesn't seem like a lot but it was it
was good for that year if you consider
the drop in the price of oil and all of
the other ancillary or see ancillary
economic activity that got affected but
this year we're forecasting over 600 so
that is a tenfold increase in three
years Hamden but here's the even better
news any growth in the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia any reform in the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia any success in the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia is very contagious for
the region
we see a very bright future as the
kingdom of saudi arabia continues to
perform and continues to invest in all
of these mega or Giga projects as
they're called in English and frankly
we've seen it I have been on the
forefront of the reform agenda well
since we first met each other about 20
years ago ladies and gentlemen when I
first met Bassam it was I I think on a
dusty day in an acaba maybe in Jordan or
was it in there one man maybe I'm not
sure it was in the red sea urchin it was
at the Red Sea Red Sea but I was 15 then
well you managed to keep I went gray but
the the dreams are still the same dreams
the view that His Royal Highness has for
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia is what we
all want for our countries and if Saudi
Arabia which is the main engine of
growth for this whole region and the
main pillar of stability is successful
and is growing then we are all doing
very well so in a nutshell ladies and
gentlemen growth in the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia is good for us please invest in
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia all of you
that are here please invest
because when you invest in the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia you are investing us and
the world is a safer place
your highness don't worry we have fifty
billion u.s. dollar yesterday and today
[Applause]
Emir Morales we read and would in a
world or a circle outside can you factor
own was stuck been heaven monk that I'm
stuck Venetian colossal I believe there
are unique projects in the Middle East
look at the Middle East after the
establishment the foundation of the UN
used natural resources especially oil in
the Gulf but a man came in the 90s and
he showed us an example a model and he
proved that we can succeed in the Middle
East chef Mohammad Russian
he presented a model in Dubai
and he met everyone in the Middle East
convinced that they can do not like the
boy but even more he increased the bar
and we want to increase the bar and say
in Saudi Arabia and everybody wants to
do the same we could see after that Abu
Dhabi moved quite forcefully with great
achievements of the rest of the Emirates
Bahrain since the Crown Prince took
office in 99 until today many great
achievements this is not to be mentioned
- or compared to what's going to happen
in the future
Kuwait today they have 2030 vision 35
vision they have great people they have
great financial resources quite easily
they will meet their goals great goals
today in Egypt
last year it was 5% or a little more a
growth into the GDP today more more than
GDP unemployment rate is declining quite
rapidly the building of housing projects
I could not believe it myself I visit
some areas in Egypt I find all the
officials there crying while working on
the ground in order to restore the great
Egypt and the powerful Egypt and despite
all of this they believe that no matter
whether what they achieved in the past
two years is nothing they haven't
started yet we could see that there's a
tremendous work led by the prime
minister in Lebanon to also restore the
great role of Lebanon and I guarantee
that the efforts of our brothers in
Lebanon will succeed under the
leadership of the prime minister and the
rest of the Lebanese leaders a Jordan
they have also quite leaps and we
participate in some of these projects
Oman they have mega projects and they're
trying to transform Oman to a new era in
addition to Saudi Arabia
I believe that Europe the new Europe is
the Middle East
[Applause]
remember like Al abuse the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia and the coming five years
will be totally different but Harun will
be totally different Kuwait even couple
despite our difference with them they
have a strong economy and they will be
totally different in five years Emirates
Oman Lebanon Jordan Egypt Iraq and the
opportunities they have if we succeed in
the next five years it will many other
countries will follow up becoming
Renaissance in the next thirty years
will be in the Middle East this is the
war of the Saudis this is my war which I
launched personally and I don't I don't
want to leave this life before seeing
the Middle East at the front forefront
of the world and it will be happen 100%
[Applause]
what up little we just how any war by
the way there are Wars where we can lose
I don't believe that we will win in
every war but for the Saudis they have
we have a mountain called the White
Mountain the the will of the Saudis is
as strong as this mountain they will be
defeated only if you can defeat and and
destroy this mountain your excellency
the Prime Minister I'd like ask me the
same question what do you expect and how
do you see that inside the future of the
Middle East after they are Prime
Minister the crown prince and said that
we will be with the Prime Minister
in war and and as well most important
His Excellency royal excellency that we
need to focus on our nations and peoples
and the growth in our countries we need
to forget we need to develop ourselves
this is the only way to to realize in
the Middle East a new kind of situation
a new future economy and this well that
complete result well economically was
ended up it is now we have the economic
walls we need to see who gets into the
markets who penetrate into the markets
of others what Eric English editor is
doing headed by the history of the
promised land the crown prince is the
basic thing because it is quite energy
in the state Kendall said Arabic I lived
in Saturday and I was educated in Saudi
Arabia this kind of energy that we seek
and have said but we've never seen
before there was a kind of bigger plans
and they have achieved actually that
again at the same time there should be
more change more transformation and as
referred by the successive opera in this
kind of change you will need to adopt a
new to take see the light and all the
nations around us around the kingdom
said Arabia with Egypt Bahrain United
Emirates in Lebanon even Iraq even in
Tunisia Morocco
ILI's countries we see that we see a
kind of development and the growth of
the economy sectors and we always focus
on our national economy all the
economy and the Arab economies which of
course reflects this kind of
developmental growth and what his
Excellency role excellency already
spoken about we can never had anything
more we just can like push it up and we
all Arabs and we all in the Middle East
we need to cooperate and collaborate so
that we create economic power energy
then after that you can communicate with
us thank you so much a few final word to
his Excellency of Bahrain what I can
Massa Tiana Pula comments are laid down
as a marker for us to rally it's a
rallying cry for us to rally around and
we will support you in all your
endeavors we're so proud to see you so
say those words and mean them 8086 years
ago we found 86 years 86 years ago we
found a tremendous resource under the
soil of the desert oil and we built
pipelines and we built refineries and we
built ports to ship that oil and that
valuable resource to the world and with
that money we built schools we built
universities we built hospitals we built
housing and we built the modern
countries in which we live today the
power that we must unleash and the Arab
world is the power of innovation
elliptical and we must give people the
tools to succeed in that
so the pipeline's that we build in the
future are lines of credit and support
for startups and for for for businesses
all over the region the refineries that
we build must be the incubators that
house and allow great ideas and
companies to be born and the ports are
the infrastructure and our connectivity
to the world whether that be physical
infrastructure in aircraft and whatnot
or the digital
infrastructure that we need so that we
can compete on an equal footing with
with any other geography that is known
to us I am so proud of his royal
highnesses pride in the people of the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia we are also
proud of the people of Bahrain I know
your excellency the people of Lebanon
are always in your mind we must be proud
as Arabs carob naphtha that arena
all too often we should we must be proud
of who we are
Willie ahem
mini lemon Konerko and who we can be we
should always push it all the way and on
this journey I wish you all well and I
am honored to be there by your side Tina
are we done I just want to conclude
Minister side is going to be here for
two days so please know the governor is
his kidnapped
[Applause]
Sadie what we could have to say one
thing with all success you should also
have someone shutting that this kind of
such a great success that kind of seller
base trying to achieve and not sharp and
a transformation is trying to realize
they always should be we should always
be some people envious of us and also we
should have people keeping us down so I
I always afraid that this will be a
well guided well protected by Allah
Prime Minister because you have restored
confidence and trust to the the our
people because you are the leadership
and you are the child because you are
devolved Innes and the innovation and
the modernization and because you
maintain suffering T and history and our
identity I would like to thank you all
[Music]